[Music]
hey you guys it's Monday Tom is going
into the neighbors video again okay this
will work scooting over into that we're
going into this there's a word over here
what's up you guys it's Monday night and
it's time for a haunting Monday sorry
we're a little bit late uh Tom
completely forgot it was like 10 minutes
before we were gonna start and I was
like um are you gonna be ready to do the
show well I had all kinds of stuff I had
to cook and he was like um I had to feed
her when she comes home at six gave her
leftovers then I had to cook a pizza for
myself
but I'm just messing because I ate those
same leftovers that was good though yeah
they were good it was a spaghetti with
uh chicken sausage like Italian chicken
sausage it was good yeah that's what I
had for lunch yeah and so I saved a
portion for her to fed her down I had a
peanut butter but I didn't have anything
to eat for dinner so I made a little
quick pizza yeah but he forgot she's not
coming home till six anyway yeah
but uh no man she caught me in the door
that [__] was ready I forgot I forgot
how to do a show I forgot about the time
you know what I mean you just one thing
leads to another I'm busy in there yeah
that's the thing so yeah but we're only
20 minutes late I mean that's not too
bad it's okay some people were liking
the later show anyway because uh you
know we got other time zones to worry
about yeah that's true okay people are
in here they're coming they're showing
up Tammy's here hey hey Tammy what's
going on and you know and thankfully
this wasn't like a super super
complicated episode this was actually a
good episode I'm surprised we didn't
never got around to doing it yet and
especially it's because it's one that's
like more Poltergeist yeah it's similar
similar to what happened in Mammoth it's
just that it wasn't as much stuff moving
but I I remembered this episode but I
forgot that it was a poltergeist case I
did as well yeah it wasn't and what was
good about it is that they went ahead
and said yeah
poltergeists are not ghosts poltergeists
are manifestations of a person's [__]
fears and inner turmoils you know
um when you linked up with some
mysterious psychic abilities telekinesis
basically but it's the
they say it's a manifestation of it
I think it's one of the other
hemispheres in the brain that's doing it
the basically the unconscious of the
subconscious that's what I think does it
same one that runs dream characters or
the characters in your dreams
that's what I think it is
um I lived it still happens every now
and then but not as good as it was when
I was 14. that's when it was real good
although this is happening to an adult
female
she seemed like older I couldn't really
tell how old she was but this is a this
is an older episode this was from season
one an older person can do it but it's
never as good as it is with a younger
person
the just statistically just read the
cases closer they are to puberty the
stronger it is
the more movement of objects the more
impressive the phenomena is
this one would be impressive to an adult
a family though they thought it was a
ghost same thing I mean grabbing people
it's some kind of weird [__] pushing
people yeah
but yeah it's just so like I said it was
just I was surprised when I was going
through the um the episode list and I
was like oh I don't even remember that
one and then like when we were watching
it I'm like I wonder why we didn't
remember this one because it was
actually pretty good and it was
Poltergeist yeah themed and that's like
usually you would have remember that
better tapping it in the southwest with
um a bunch of uh like Latin American
Catholics it's good it's a good one
yeah and they had both they had the
couple on there like the um the mom and
the dad and I think a couple of the kids
too one of the daughters on there yeah
like growing up at least one of them was
yeah I think they had two daughters and
two sons but they didn't um I don't
think they ever said what the son's
names were but they said what the girl's
name so the kids weren't all that
involved in what was going on you know
what I mean yeah Camp guy said I made
pancakes with ricotta and lemon zest oh
that'd be good that's a good thick
sliced bacon oh my God that feels like
that sounds good yeah save me some yeah
I made pancakes in a long time I got
pancake pre-made pancake mix sitting
down there five pounds of it just
sitting there aging we need to start
making
you know what I it's funny because this
weekend I think when we were coming home
from the club I was just kind of like
man I could go for a big stack of
pancakes right now yeah like I just
really wanted some because yeah I
haven't had any in a really long time or
waffles I was just like man I want some
pancakes or some waffles or some [__]
got that waffle iron down there I
haven't used in a long time I know maybe
we should make some this weekend
get some strawberries or something every
time I put this damn wig on I always
have like a phantom hair yeah I guess it
like comes in it's like always like
caught behind my glasses and then I
can't like it's a closed hair I can feel
it but I can't move it it's like driving
me [__] crazy
so uh so is everybody in there we ready
to start talking about some ghosts and
[__] yeah we'll technically not ghosts I
know we're not gonna get like all
pedantic about it but they kind of lead
you to believe that it's ghosts but then
they spring it on you spoiler alert then
it's actually not yeah well they it
matter that you know she she saw some
apparitions and it was doing stuff
that a ghost would do and that's what
she thought it was but it turned out
that's not what it was yeah and I I've
been there done that we that's what we
thought it was but we didn't know
anything about it well I mean you would
think that something invisible you know
so
ghost or demon or something you know but
it wasn't ours wasn't that violent so
ghost you know yeah this one was a
little uh cranky yeah
this episode is called cursed which
is kind of a pain because these ones
that have these really generic titles
like that it's really hard to like find
any other like outside information on
them because it's like everything else
everything yeah yeah it's like really
hard to find stuff but yeah so this is
from season one and it's episode four
so this whole thing took place in I
don't even think they said what year did
they say what year this happened uh not
that I remember but I was thinking I was
thinking 90s maybe maybe they mentioned
it but it's like usually if they mention
it I would have written it down and I
didn't write it down yeah I wrote down
the location and I usually write down
the location in the year but they must
not have said because I didn't write it
down unless I just wasn't listening it
was the Southwest somewhere in Nevada it
was Tucson Arizona it is where it was
see I did write that down but I don't
know what year it was because I think I
was waiting for them to say what year
and I don't think they ever said and as
it doesn't matter
so uh the couple at the heart of this
are named Romy and Fernando I think they
said their last name was whole bean
yeah I don't remember or something like
that I couldn't tell exactly like what
they were saying but it sounded like
whole bean to me yeah like whole bean or
like hot or like Hans Holbein that that
middle that paper probably just
pronunciation of something Latin or that
was a that was not a maiden name that
was a married name she may have been she
was divorced I think wouldn't you yeah
or I don't know I just I couldn't hear
it really so that was what I wrote down
because that was it was a Hispanic
family yeah yeah yeah so they had four
kids um like I said the kids didn't
Factor too much into it this time they
only really mentioned both of them's
names and they didn't really mention any
of their ages I think two of them were
girls and two were boys
so at the beginning they're actually
staying with romy's Mom while they're
looking for a new place to live
so they've been kind of like driving
around like looking for some place to
rent or buy or what have you and one
particular day she said while they were
driving around she felt like
inexplicably pulled to this particular
neighborhood and to a particular house
now this house
um they didn't like come right out and
say this but it kind of looked like a
dump is what I gathered uh but it just
looked like a piece of [__]
and so they start asking uh the
neighbors like what's the deal with this
house and they're like oh that house is
abandoned and nobody's lived in it for a
long time and it's like whenever anybody
ever moved in like they never stay for
very long and then they get the [__] out
so even though it looks like a [__]
apparently
um Romy is like obsessed with it for
whatever reason like I said she has some
kind of like weird attraction toward it
so she starts like obsessively calling
around like trying to figure out who
owns it so that they can buy it off them
so um she also mentions around this time
that she has had the same weird
recurring nightmare uh ever since she
was a child now what they showed on the
show like the reenactment of it it's
almost like she's standing in it looked
like a basement like with a dirt floor
and she's like looking down at the floor
and I think it looks like her feet were
bare and then there's like a skeleton
like kind of partially buried in the
dirt coming out of the dirt like coming
out of the dirt and then would now did I
see this wrong no it's a garden hose
well there's a garden hose yeah and it
was like kind of suspended over like it
was shooting like water into the
skeleton's mouth it was coming out of
the ground and then bending over yeah
and shooting a full stream of water into
its mouth that's what she kept seeing
which is really weird because it's like
they they showed that image like a
couple of times I'm like that's oddly
specific but it didn't but it didn't
really yeah but it never really like
factored into anything like what you
know it didn't mean anything but I just
thought that was like what a weird thing
to Dream well in retrospect with the
case and everything I thought it was she
was dreaming it so it was coming from
her subconscious mind same place the
Poltergeist come from it was a
manifestation of some kind of stress or
fear that she had
somebody dead in the desert trying to
die a thirst and then just being drowned
in the water that type of deal yeah
maybe that's what it was it was
something it was two opposites happening
at the same time something it was like
that conflict that something from her
unconscious mind or subconscious mind
imagery
which I think started the Poltergeist
because the fear
yeah conflict
so that's what it that's my
interpretation of it
yeah maybe that's because it did seem
like kind of like she was inside but it
seemed like sand yeah like on the floor
of this basement or whatever Arizona is
a desert yeah Arizona's a desert okay
what's the biggest danger in the desert
died of thirst yeah so the skeleton's
dead but it's got all the water it needs
that kind of deal
um in the desert so it's just uh
almost kind of like a creation
destruction picture like a yin yang
type thing like a
snake swallowing its own tail that type
of imagery they can oroboros yeah so
it's just uh
the big it was a it was a vision of her
stress and her interferes
and it was centered around that house
maybe buying that house
was stressful at first and it just kind
of snowballed it into that and because
it was abandoned
she was slightly afraid of that house
and didn't know why she was obsessed
with it so she starts thinking about
ghosts
something like that yeah
I mean it seemed like she said that
she'd had that same dream about the
skeleton and the hose presumably like
since she was a kid so like I said that
seemed like a very oddly specific since
she was a kid okay yeah
so that's also a factor it was some kind
of childhood some kind of childhood fear
case maybe she got lost in the desert
once when she was a kid it was just an
image that scared her as a kid some of
the subconscious comes up with yeah I
mean it is pretty weird because I'm like
looking at it going is that like a hose
that's like that's very strange
but he had a meaning to her it's just
that she didn't realize what the meaning
was right yeah
so finally after calling all over the
place she finally finds the person who
owns this house and she buys it off them
now she says her brother is like a
carpenter or a contractor or something
like that and so he's gonna give him a
deal and like fix it all up and
everything
so after a few months uh you know it's
all kind of fixed up and they
move in at this point they do like a
fake jump scare where they're like like
down the hall and then like hand on the
shoulder and it's like oh hi honey don't
sneak up on me like that yeah so they
they did like some fake jumps to your
action at that at that point
so that it seemed like the night that
they moved in maybe or like not too long
after they moved in
uh the girls the daughters uh their
names are Veronica and Angelica they
didn't say what the son's names were
but they said they woke up in the middle
of the night and they thought that they
heard their brothers talking in the
hallway
so they get up and they go out into the
Hall to see what the deal is
now the one girl the older girl I don't
know which one was older or younger but
the older girl kind of like goes down
the hall and she like looks in the
bathroom
and apparently her younger sister is
standing in the bathroom like at the
sink like doing her hands on the sink
like that was pretty freaky well
actually like doing this like on the
sink and she's like what the [__] like
her and then she turns around and her
sister is like just behind her
she saw like a doppelganger of the
sister because the sister's like well
who do you see and she's like what the
[__] and then she looks back and like
there's nobody there I'm like ooh that
would be like really creepy to me that
would be even creepier than seeing like
a ghost of like some random [__]
that you don't know who it is yeah like
just so like if I if you were with me
and then I looked over there and then
there was like another you like a ghost
you or something like that that was like
I would [__] who was it that saw it
again it was the sister no these are the
daughters okay so one of the daughters
saw that saw the sister she they both
came out the room and then like one of
them like the little or one hung back
and the older one kind of went down the
hall a little bit looked in the bathroom
and then she saw the little sister in
the bathroom he wasn't there it wasn't
her but she wasn't her like she was
behind her
it's unusual because Poltergeist cases
usually don't have any kind of
apparitions or at least human human
looking apparitions or at least nothing
that's con nothing that convinces you
that it's a solid person you know
you might see hazy stuff and blue
spheres and hazy that kind of stuff but
you never usually you don't usually see
what appears to be a solid Apparition of
person
is strange I'd like to hear that girl's
story in her own words
you know yeah did they take liberties
with the story I don't know I mean I
imagine because I think they usually do
yeah it's not typical Poltergeist that
kind of phenomena
yeah I mean
I have written about some cases where
that happened though like even the
doppelganger kind of thing really like
where people saw apparitions of like
living people it's rare or saw like two
you know saw like you know they they saw
somebody in the house and then it's like
you know then the real person came home
you know what I mean it's rare in
Poltergeist cases yeah it is it's like I
but I remember like writing about a
couple where that specific thing
happened it makes you wonder if it's if
that part of the story is fabricated or
if the story is fabricated I'm just
saying yeah I don't know
but like I said that would be pretty
weird like seeing a [__] doppelganger
of your sister when they're like
standing right there you know what I
mean that's like really weird and I
think I was weirded out I don't know why
this kind of [__] words me out but I was
weirded out that the little girl was
just like looking in the mirror like
doing her hands on the sink like that
yeah I was like I don't know why that
freaked me out so much but it did
the one that we had was strong enough to
move objects on a regular basis on
command and interact with you
but it kind of was kind of an ebb and
flow with it it would do it for a few
hours and kind of fade off and then come
back for a few hours and fade off
um
I would think that if it could make a a
convincing Apparition it would have
we did see some like blue haze type
phenomenon
at a distance
and uh kind of a spherical things up
around the corner of the
ceiling like about the size of a
softball or a grapefruit about like that
but you'd try to look right at it and
you couldn't you couldn't see it but if
you looked a little bit to the side of
it you could see it it was kind of like
when you rub your eyes you see colors
it's like that it was just a round ball
and it was just kind of like a warped
area but if you tried to focus directly
on it it wouldn't be there you'd have to
look to the side and you could kind of
see it out of your peripheral vision you
felt like it was watching you from there
that's the only things that are close to
an apparition I would think that if if a
poltergeist could make an apparition it
was real convincing it ours would have
done it
because it did everything else including
tried to speak but it was just garble
couldn't understand what it said
out of thin air man scared the [__] out
of me ran from it
yeah in the middle of the night when I
was in bed yeah it was weird couldn't
understand what you're saying it sounded
like it was underwater and backwards
so uh so I guess a couple of nights
after the whole sister thing I don't
think that they told the parents like
what they saw
or heard because they thought they heard
their brothers too but their brothers
were obviously were not in the hallway
so a couple nights after that Romy the
mom she wakes up in the middle of the
night and she said that she sensed
someone in the room I don't think she
saw anybody at first
but she said she felt like somebody was
in there and then they kind of had her
looking out in the hall and she was like
what the [__] like she thought somebody
was like running around out there so she
goes out to check on the kids
everybody's asleep like nobody's walking
around
now Romy is starting to have this kind
of like feeling all the time like in her
room like like she's always like sensing
presences and whatnot yeah but but she
doesn't tell anybody about it yeah
so a couple nights after that she's very
restless again she can't really sleep
and she keeps like you know tossing and
turning or whatever and then she wakes
up at some point and like looks above
her and I'm guessing this is what they
showed on the um reenactment anyway was
that she sees kind of like a Dark Mist
type situation it didn't really look
like a person but it kind of looked like
a Mist with like a little bit of a
suggestion of a face Maybe well that's
it kind of like kind of floating above
the bed that matches with with what we
saw remember the blue haze
and things that are kind of spherical
yeah okay I'll buy that
I could I could
if the Poltergeist can make that kind of
blue film Haze
it could also
shape it into something that was a rough
face I'm pretty sure I could do that I
mean that's kind of like I said I don't
think she said that she saw that but
that's what they showed on the
reenactment could it just kind of looked
like a misty thing that sort of kind of
looked like a face like a face right
there was like kind of a lot of like
Misty sort of apparitions yeah yeah I
think really the only clear one was the
one where the sister saw the other
sister it was low res yeah yeah yeah you
know when you see it for real it's low
resolution it's not real crisp you're
not even really sure it's there you know
it's there everybody can agree that yeah
it's there but when you try to get up on
it and look at it you can't see you kind
of have to relax your eyes and kind of
back off of it at a distance and you'll
see kind of like a haze
it was weird you know so maybe that's
what this was yeah it's probably what
they're talking about and it felt like
it was looking at you
yeah yeah no could it make like a vague
face probably possibly maybe that was
just the show Taking Liberties
you know what I mean so they put a face
in it I don't know
put a face in that [__]
so uh one day not too long after all of
this uh Romy and her sister are I guess
they do kind of like a Meals on Wheels
kind of situation so they're taking food
to like an elderly neighbor of theirs
and they never met this guy before I
guess
but they go in and she's like the old
guy like shook her hand and immediately
said there's a spirit in your house like
he like he could see it you know I mean
even though she'd never met him before
yeah that's a that's a that is a psychic
phenomenon what's it called uh tactic no
where you touch something or a person I
know I care
what's I don't know what
and you can get images from touching
something
okay
yeah
so the guy tells her
um you know yeah like your house is
haunted and [__] but it's like don't be
scared you should follow the dark spirit
and um romy's like nah doc I'm not doing
that I don't think she said that to him
but she was like thinking that she was
like no I'm not doing that which I you
know I don't blame her
um and then he tells her that her house
is a gateway that's what he says
so Romy says okay well I'm definitely
not I don't like this Gateway business
and I'm not gonna like follow this
[__] Spirit around or whatever I'm
just gonna
um ignore it and just hope that it goes
away so this psychic suggests that it's
a ghost tour so it's gonna start acting
like a ghost yeah
although he may have just picked up the
fact that she's very psychically charged
and that she was manifested in a
poltergeist
yeah maybe that's what he said like I
said she said she'd never met him before
she's an old guy like that lived on the
same street right his psychic abilities
and his his knowledge interpreted that
as oh well she's got a ghost in her
house
but maybe he didn't know about
Poltergeist
you know
so he's that was his interpretation
right I kind of predict if this story is
true and the guy was a psychic
more plausible that he picked up a
psychic charge off of her and got a view
that there was a disturbance in her
house
and he just thought that that meant
ghost
but Poltergeist different very different
she's making it herself
Muslims were called a gin
you know your interpretation of what's
happening is going to be based upon your
culture
you know uh
because that's the framework you're
working out of this guy ghost okay
yeah
so uh not too long after that
she has the skeleton dream again yeah
but this time and I don't think this had
happened previously that was the
implication anyway but the skeleton that
was in the dirt like his arm comes out
of the dirt and grabs her leg and like
pulls it and then apparently in real
life because she was dreaming that but
then apparently in real life like
something like legit pulls her out of
bed like by her leg you know what I mean
like she's kind of like pulled out and
like pulled off the edge yeah so it's
you know it wasn't a skeleton she didn't
see a skeleton in real life I guess but
she was dreaming that and apparently
that was like really uh what happened
and so like she waits she tries to wake
up Fernando like her husband but he
doesn't wake up right away but then
finally he wakes up and she's like down
at the end of the bed being like what
the [__] like I just got pulled out of
bed you know what I mean yeah I had that
fear in the Poltergeist house up at map
Mount I had two fears when I was
sleeping that something would grab me by
the ankle and pull me off the bed never
happened the other fear was that
something would grab his sheets and pull
it off the bed
yeah because I saw it do that you know
I love being a little red I saw the
wasn't the sheet it was a comforter
slide off a bit
that was [__] bizarre so I was
afraid that it would pull covers off of
you but it never did
I think I'd be more scared that it was
gonna grab my ankle to be honest with
you yeah you know try to keep my feet
from the edge of the bed you know
or even a couch if we were because we
were sleeping in the couch in the
[__] Hideaway the hide a bit after
because Poltergeist or a couch they
don't need any room yeah that was some
weird [__] man going back to those days
but yeah so apparently skeleton arm just
like pulls her out of bed so Fernando
it's like he doesn't he actually seemed
like pretty supportive but he hadn't
really seen anything at this point
but he's not one of those [__]
on the show that's like you're crazy I
don't say anything blah blah blah he was
just I think he just didn't really know
what to do you know what I mean more
than anything
um so at this point and you had this
happen in your thing too but like the
whole family starts sleeping in the
living room yeah that's that's the only
thing you can do you're scared me by
yourself you got to keep an eye on
everybody yeah well that's what they're
doing so they're all sleeping out living
room with all the kids and they don't
really say anything to the kids however
they said that one of the sons
says to the mom oh I know why we're all
sleeping out here it's because of the
Man in Black and I said Johnny Cash you
guys are all sleeping in the living room
because of Johnny Cash apparently not
um apparently the kid has been seeing
an apparition too but the weird thing
about it is that Romy said the kids
didn't really seem
scared they were just kind of like
whatevs you know what I mean that's
unusual which yeah I thought that was a
little odd too like I said they didn't
really talk to the kids to any great
degree or anything so I don't even see
any phenomena yeah but if it well I mean
if one of the sons knew
like if he said to her like oh about the
man in Black that's why we're all
sleeping out here so obviously one of
them at least had seen something and one
of the daughters said she saw the other
sister like a doppelganger with the
other sister so you'd think they'd be
freaking out but maybe they were just
kind of like oh well I suppose that
happens
that's unusual I mean they are Latino
and they're Catholics so they they
already know about things like condom
play macumba Santeria the idea of
spirits you know
so they're already kind of comfortable
with that
so maybe that kind of cushioned it
but usually kids are terrified of
poltergeist well yeah I would imagine
that they would be throwing objects can
move things you feel like you're being
watched you know you assume it's a
[__] demon and they do feel kind of
dangerous yeah
but if you get light-hearted it starts
to get light-hearted too it just mirrors
whatever your feelings are yeah but when
you're terrified it [__] scares the
[__] out of you
pull the dab chain off pull a chain off
a [__] door and [__]
yeah it's weird it's bad yeah got
something out of them
worse than any of the [__] that movie
was worse
but yeah so I mean at least according to
Romy she said the kids didn't really
seem all that scared or all that upset
about it but um Romy absolutely is
because she's like well if the kids are
seeing it too then that's probably not
good because she probably she thought it
was like dangerous you know what I mean
so Fernando actually like I said unlike
a lot of the guys um that are featured
on the show he basically says maybe we
should sell the house and move like he
hasn't seen anything at this point but
he's like look it's obviously like
upsetting you and you know it's not
worth it
but um she said she didn't really want
to I don't know if it was just because
she still was obsessed with the house
and really liked it or she didn't want
what she thought was a ghost to like run
her out of her own home or I don't
really know what her reasoning was I
don't think she really articulated it
but she just didn't want to move
um and basically she said I'm just gonna
suck it up uh the kids seem okay they're
not afraid um you know so I guess we'll
just keep on keeping on
now not too long after this though Romy
said that she felt something again like
pulling on her while she was sleeping
um and then when she woke up Fernando
said man you were like so Restless like
all last night he was just flopping all
over the place and then after after he
leaves for work she looks at her arm and
there's like teeth marks on her arm yeah
it's from the shoulder all the way down
the elbow like huge teeth marks yeah
like a [__] shark or something yeah
like a giant man and they're crooked
crooked teeth that's pretty weird it's
what they showed I don't know if that's
the way it really looked yeah I mean it
might have just been like a little
scratch or something they just wanted to
make it look like super scary now this
goes back to uh the Rain Man rain man I
think he had bite marks on him too
didn't he
I don't actually remember
who Decker Decker yeah dying Decker I
think he died didn't he I I don't know
okay yeah I gotta see if Decker still I
wanted to get him on a show yeah maybe
he'd make a rain that can make things
[__] throw throw [__]
make things disappear yeah I make a [__]
disappear man and appear out of nowhere
it's kind of a pain in the ass yeah
then pull [__] molding off the damn
counter tops and [__]
yeah yeah
so yeah so I like I said I don't know
what the real teeth marks looked like
they were pretty impressive on the show
gonna say like I said it looked like a
big [__] it looked like like a
[__] shark bitter or a giant thumb
so when she gets to work she actually
like goes to like a friend of hers that
worked like a colleague or something and
she's like I gotta show you this kind of
like I guess she wanted like some
outside validation or something and so
she shows this other lady she's like
check this [__] out and she's like holy
[__] what the [__] like what [__] you
and uh so she's like okay well I'm not
crazy then because somebody else sees it
too so then when she goes home and she
shows it to Fernando and again he's like
super freaked out he's like for real
like we should move okay because this is
like this is not good
um so there and from this point they
just all sleep in the living room for
they said they slept in the living room
for like the next six months or
something like that
and then the next thing that happened on
the show was that um Romy I think she
like wakes up in the middle of the night
or it was late at night or something and
she wakes up and she's like I have to go
see my aunt like her aunt had been in
the hospital like she knew that
but she's like I have to go to her like
right now and Fernando's like what the
[__] it's like midnight or whatever it
is but she just like throws on her
clothes and gets in the car and goes to
the hospital and when she gets there
like her aunt said what took you so long
I've been calling you and calling you
like not calling her on the phone but
like psychically calling her I guess and
so she's like okay well I'm here now and
she's like her aunt died like an hour
later so it's like she was trying to
call her like to come
see her like before she died or
something like that
now uh again this this there's kind of
like this one doesn't really have like a
narrative through line so much it's just
kind of like a series of weird
occurrences which like you know that's
some of them are like that but that's
okay
um then a little while after that she
said one afternoon a neighbor from you
know somebody that lived in a
neighborhood for a while they came over
and told her oh by the way
that um a lot of people like this house
is kind of [__] up and that's like
kind of why like it was abandoned for so
long there's like there was a teenage
boy I think and he had he had shot
himself in the house like killed himself
and then like his dad came home and
found the body and then the dad hanged
himself in the house like after he found
his son's body the same day I guess I
mean I don't think they said yeah that's
pretty [__] up but it's like I'd hate
to have to clean that mess up too that's
Jesus Christ yeah it reminded me of
something that was kind of like that
what's that kind of a kind of a sad but
heartwarming story
I don't remember the names involved
but they had this guy who was in
California he was a famous bodybuilder
and his wife was this uh kind of big
titty poster chick with the you know
like they put on the posters and shoot
the big fake implants during the early
80s or so they were in their 40s then
and they were a happy couple you know
and everybody knew him you know they
show up on the scene and
he uh evidently he woke up and found a
wife dead next to him and he called his
friends he was at on the phone he goes
dude he goes she's dead give me some
help he's like okay man they're on the
way and when they showed up they found
him
in the in the chair next to the bed
where she was laying dead and he was
dead he had a pistol in his hand but it
wasn't shot
just died of a broken heart
damn yeah
so I guess like if he had Epistles he
was thinking about everything about
himself but he didn't ever do it but
either he died died of a broken heart
holy [__] it does happen I have heard of
that happening yep and and that dude was
on was heading straight to his house and
it was only like 15-20 minute drive so
it didn't take it didn't take him long
he had a
38 special pistol just still sitting in
his hand on his lap
what did she die of do they know
um it was like a heart attack or
something
yeah so I'm gonna sleep stay we're in
their 60s
okay I was for some reason like they
were younger they were old he was at
that time he was in his 60s yeah I was
gonna say that happened sometimes too
with like a lot of um older couples that
have been together for a reason yeah
they were together for a long time
because they're just so used to like
being around one another that yeah died
the same day of a broken heart
that's so sad yeah yeah Zach said I've
heard that happening to elderly couples
a lot yeah it's usually yeah well yeah
like I said if you've been because [__]
man I
I knew some older people like you know
they're dead now obviously but you know
they'd been married like 40 50 years
something like that can you imagine like
being like seeing somebody for every day
for 40 or 50 years and then like
suddenly they're gone like it would be
like really [__] yeah you wouldn't be
able to like deal with it but you can
probably and then you will yourself to
die
shows you how powerful the mind is it is
yeah just gave up the ghost I'm always
kind of like worried that I'm gonna
accidentally like do that you know what
I mean is that a stupid thing to think
but I know that well I know that it can
happen like I know that people can do it
yeah so it's like sometimes now I'm
always like paranoid that might have
like some fleeting thought about some
[__] like that it's like oh [__] now I'm
gonna like really make that happen yeah
I need to quit thinking that stop it
stop it you know what I mean I mean I
guess you really really have to like
commit to it I suppose but I don't know
I'm still kind of paranoid about it
um so yeah
so after this Neighbor comes over and
gives her this little cheerful nugget of
information about the two suicides that
took place in the house
um which like I said I guess they were
trying to imply
the weird thing about it is they seemed
like the whole time they were trying to
apply that there was something inherent
in the house that was like it was
haunted or some [__] like that because
she was saying it's like oh she was
attracted to it at first and blah blah
but then in the end you kind of figure
out that it really didn't have anything
to do with that but apparently like some
people thought the house was maybe
haunted before they moved in I mean I
thought that was the implication just
because they
just because everybody was like talking
about how everybody left the house like
nobody stayed for that long and people
had died in their blog
so uh weirdly after she gets this
information Romy they said she was
mostly fine like for a few months
they're like I guess the the um activity
kind of tapered off for a little while
um I think like some stuff happened but
nothing like real egregious or anything
but then uh one night Fernando actually
wakes up in the bedroom and he said that
he felt all around him it felt like an
ice cold wind like not natural feeling
right and then he sees they didn't
really show exactly what he sees but he
said like he seemed to be describing
like it's like a black mist or like a
black figure of some kind or like a
weird shadow figure or something
um so he saw it too like he saw it like
coming into the bedroom it seemed like
um so Romy wakes up but he doesn't tell
her exactly what he saw because like she
had enough problems it's like you know
she didn't really need me to
say hey I saw like a freaky black figure
coming to the room that's like you know
so at this point they call up the Deacon
uh to come over and bless the house
so he comes over and does the thing and
they actually had the the real Deacon on
there talking for a few minutes
and then right afterward
um Romy said she felt fine like for the
rest of that day it was just like oh
yeah maybe it worked
but then
um as soon as it was night time again
she started feeling like something was
horribly horribly wrong and she started
to suspect that maybe the blessing made
the spirit stronger which she's probably
seen other episodes of the show because
that's usually what happens
um so she apparently like was like yeah
I don't really like the feeling in the
in this place anymore and so she started
sleeping because I guess they'd started
sleeping in their bedrooms again because
everything had kind of calmed down but
then when Fernando comes home from work
on this particular day like romy's
sleeping in the living room again and
then after this they kind of imply that
again the activity sort of tapered off
because they said at this point like
years go by now Fernando and Romy still
live in the same house but their kids
like grow up and move out and have kids
of their own and [__] like that so it's
been like a while like that's been going
on
now one of the daughters
um has a son named Alex so that's Romeo
and Fernando's grandson
now they noticed that the kid has an
imaginary friend that he calls Michael
and he talks to this Michael person all
the time and he says that sometimes
Michael tells him to do things which you
know kind of like demon Childs yeah
why would you hurt the kitty but yeah so
um
why did you why did you pee in the
closet
no no what do you say man said it was
okay
and that is okay
so so apparently Alec is seeing man yeah
and man's telling him to do things
[Laughter]
maybe I said I could pee in the closet
sure why not yeah I mean you're not the
one that has to do laundry why not yeah
it's a little room you can pee in that
it'd be all right
so thinking of a little kid yeah yeah
it's it's kind of like it's like an
outhouse yeah indoors none of y'all know
how to say it out of mind yeah but yeah
so he was peeing on his own clothes too
he was yeah he's marking his territory
that's what he was doing he thought that
she was cool I guess yeah little boys
are gross but especially when they're
under the influence of a demon
so so yeah so this kid is like seeing an
imaginary friend and Veronica who is the
daughter that was you know Alex mom
she was like well she's like At first I
didn't think anything was weird because
you know a lot of kids have imaginary
friends like [__] my brother had one I
remember but um that he used to sit back
on the couch and talk to him all the
time
but um as it goes on she's like we
started to figure out that he was
actually afraid of his imaginary friend
which is not usually something that uh
that kids have with their imaginary
friend it's supposed to be a friend not
an imaginary enemy you know what I mean
so um apparently like he's sitting up
they they kind of show the kid like in
the bedroom and he just keeps like
sitting up and he like thinks he hears
something in the closet like something's
talking to him or something's like
moving around in there and so he calls
out to his mom and his mom comes in but
there's you know nobody in there
and then uh after she leaves like he's
like oh there's still something in there
and then like there's like the hand
comes around the door or whatever and
he's like wow you know what I mean so
now a week after that
Alec is at Romeo and Fernando's house so
he's visiting the grandparents
and
um the kid actually falls down the
stairs and he said that somebody pushed
him like at first he thought that
Grandpa like Fernando pushed him and
he's like why would I do that I'm your
Grandpa I'm not gonna push you down the
stairs but he's like yeah somebody
pushed me down the stairs he said it
looked like like his shoulder went out
like that and he just kind of thought if
he wasn't hurt like really bad that he
was just like bruised a little bit he
didn't break any bones or nothing but um
yeah Romy is like starting to freak out
she's like oh [__] like this [__]
ghost or whatever the hell it is is back
like because I guess for many years it
had been sort of like look down on the
down low you know what I mean like it
hadn't been like really bad
so because the thing apparently like
pushed this little kid down the stairs
run me calls in the paranormal
investigators uh and the one she called
was named Amy Allen and she was played
by they had the real woman on there too
but the she was played by that same uh
actress that's on like what the [__]
other one was she in she was in a
million [__] episodes
I can't remember she's like that she has
like that kind of red-headed and she has
that real thin face no I don't remember
yeah but she's yeah you you remember
that real psychic girl she was in
several yeah she was too yeah like maybe
she's kind of well known in that area
I'm not really sure but yeah so
to this Amy Allen woman
they have a team come out and they have
two different psychics and they come
there like separately so like the first
psychic comes there and she kind of
Senses something she's like oh there's
some like a dark entity or whatever and
then they bring in a second psychic and
she kind of says the same thing like
apparently independently now one thing
they wanted to check for was that the
house was really near was it like a cell
phone tower was I don't remember if it
was a cell phone tower or just like some
kind of power transformer kind of deal
and they were just like oh maybe there's
like really high electromagnetic energy
like in the area and she also said
something about
that maybe
something like the house was kind of
like sucking in uh
uh Romy and Fernando's energy even
though they were still alive and it was
becoming absorbed like into the house
and like reflected back out into it did
she said something like that like a
stone tape kind of situation yeah which
is thank you Jeffy art yeah we just just
got out of class what did I miss yeah
all kinds of [__] all kinds of girls
yeah that theory I don't buy into that
theory it does there's no reason why
psychic memories would be encoded into
into a
physical material that way yeah because
it would just be a lot more probable
that it's recorded in in a slightly
parallel dimension in other words that
that and then that would
so you know what I mean the location
really wouldn't matter and the and
whether or not an uh a building was
standing wouldn't matter
what happened in the past happened in a
place and a time and you could access it
no matter where you were in this
Dimension so that goes back to the kind
of like the akashic records
Theory that you know what I mean that
time
is a singularity it's it's all past
present and future are all happening at
the same time you're just passing
through it
the stuff from other times and other
places are in other dimensions
basically
if you come up out of this one you might
be able to access another place and
another and that's more likely
because it involves other dimensions
which we don't really can't
you can't really disprove those but you
I'm pretty sure you could disprove
that memories and the past are not
recorded in physical medium like walls
now
you could I'm sure but that was kind of
a thing like in the 70s in the 70s they
thought because well yeah and I was
gonna say that I even did um a review
there was a British TV movie called The
Stone tape and that's where the the name
came from yeah is from that movie and it
was uh I think it was written by Nigel
Neal actually who wrote a lot of stuff
from over there and it's actually pretty
good and that was kind of the whole
um premise of that was they were going
in this scientific team and they were uh
they I don't think they actually went
there they didn't they weren't
paranormal investigators they were like
audio science scientists or something
and they were like working on some new
technological breakthrough and they went
to this they were moving their offices
to this old uh Mansion or this old
castle or something like that and then
they started getting all these weird
like audio anomalies and they figured
out that like all the hauntings had like
seeped into the walls and it was like
replaying them well I think it's more
likely that the past is stored in the
past all right it's not stored in the
walls the past is stored in the past and
there may be a way you can access
information from the past in the same
way you could access information from
the future and have a premonition that
is that's what they're talking about
yeah it's more it's a lot more plausible
because at least some of the science is
there the past is in the past
there may be a part of you that's
outside of space-time in a slightly
other dimension like a Quantum version
of yourself somewhere who could see the
past or the future or at least access it
slightly I don't believe it's recorded
in any
walls
well see that's why I thought it was
really I thought it was really
interesting that she said that because I
was like yeah that's like a 70s like a
stone tape kind of yeah kind of deal and
you didn't really you don't really see a
lot of the paranormal investigators like
talk like going for that angle yeah so I
thought it was I you know I don't think
that it's it you know I don't think it's
real I don't really think that's legit
but I just thought it was interesting
that they brought it up because I don't
really think that anyone else has
brought it up on the show it's far more
likely that the past is stored and
recorded in the past
in in in space-time and you may be able
to access that or a part of you may be
able to access that yeah that would make
a lot more that makes a lot more sense
than the walls sucking in your energy
yeah
which
that's kind of what she was and I guess
I guess the way she was talking about it
was kind of like a roundabout way of
getting to like what she was saying but
she she was kind of saying that's like
oh the energy that was coming off the
living people like it was already
starting to get absorbed into the
atmosphere or whatever the [__] as far
as I know I've never had a a premium or
I've never had a vision of the past
but I have had visions of the future
dream you dream true you dream something
and it comes true or you have a feeling
that something will happen it happened a
lot when I was a little kid I have a
feeling that something would happen and
it would happen
what does that mean there may be part of
your Consciousness that's slightly
outside of space-time that can see it
coming
Maybe
maybe even in my adult life I've had
feelings that came true things that came
true premonition type things
yeah
but some people say well it might just
be intuition but sometimes it's involves
specific people and things that I
couldn't have known you know I mean it's
just but unless you were me I wouldn't
you really wouldn't understand it you
know it's a Tom thing you wouldn't
understand
here's another shirt
[Laughter]
well my first wife as soon as I saw her
was in a club as soon as I saw her I
said I Heard a Voice say that's your
wife that's your future wife you're
gonna get married or that happened
now did I fulfill that I don't know too
many coincidences happened why would you
think that
I don't know I have heard of like some
people said I never felt like that but
yeah I heard a voice say that's your
wife you're gonna marry her huh I heard
that in my face in my mind I heard that
in your face
then I just shook it off but that came
true yeah yeah weird yeah and it came
true pretty quick a matter of a few
weeks but we were living together it was
a whirlwind thing you know what I mean
yeah
uh there's no way just by looking at
some girl you could come up with some
[__] like that
because too many things fell into place
where she lived you know what I mean was
pretty near me [__] uh the situation
she was just breaking up with a
boyfriend I had just moved to too many
damn coincidences for me to come up with
some [__] like that I'd never seen that
woman yeah and she was cute but she
wasn't
you know Head and Shoulders cute above
everybody else and I'm thinking oh I
wish I could that's not what it was yeah
I just instantly knew
I got that message
yeah
weird huh that is weird yeah and at that
time when I was younger so I did that
[__] more more recent more often
probably when you probably the first
time you saw me your psychic thing said
look at that stupid [__] over there
I remember the first time I saw you
actually
you weren't alone that's true yeah I
ignored you you were with a guy yeah so
I don't even remember first time I saw
you that's true if you're with if you're
with a with a dude I got a filter oh
you're invisible laughs
that's really funny yeah
yeah you're already spoken for us yes
oh yeah
in general if you're over 40 you're
invisible
too
very rare because you look at a lot of
women just the average woman over 40 I
mean she's you just you just you're just
invisible
well yeah women are very aware of that
yeah actually a lot of them I kind of
feel like a lot of them are relieved
especially ones that were like really
really pretty when they were younger and
they just got like a bunch of unwanted
attention so like once you get a little
bit older it's kind of like shoot I can
like actually walk around without people
like now if she's a good looking 40 year
old golf chick that's totally different
they're not they're not invisible right
but if you're over 40 hanging out the
Oasis over there and the [__] right
now you're invisible
yeah
it's true yeah
it's true
hear that lady
you're better use it while you before
you lose
or like I said it's probably like a
relief to like yeah I don't think women
care no they probably don't well look
what they have to deal with that's what
I'm saying it's like they're just
probably like shoot thank God they can
just it's like I can just go and get
sick I can just go and like get a cup of
coffee without like some dude like
fogging up on me like all the time
but yeah uh so okay so the paranormal
team are actually going to spend the
night there
but I'm assuming this was the same night
I mean like I said there's I'm not real
clear on like all the timeline on this
one
but Romy is like she's in her room and
she can't sleep again like she's having
like hard time sleeping she said that
she felt like her room was full of
people that's which that's what she said
it felt like even though obviously just
Fernando was in there
and she like couldn't take it so she's
like she gets up in the middle of night
she starts like packing her [__] like I
gotta get out of here there's like too
many [__] people in this room
but I guess they kind of like talked her
down from that now the next morning they
all have they're all sitting around
breakfast and like the the team is like
talking to them and they're like okay we
have sensed like some kind of weird Dark
Energy something and one of the psychics
or both psychics said that there are two
portals in the house I don't know that
didn't really like factor into anything
and then
um they said maybe Romy is like really
sensitive to the energy and maybe that's
why she's the one that's like
experiencing all this stuff and the rest
of her family didn't really seem to
experience it at least to the same
degree and also I think the psychic was
asking her it's like how can you even
stand to live here because this [__] is
like really haunted and there's portals
and whatnot and they're like you're like
super sensitive and don't seem to be
aware of it I guess was what they were
getting at
so at this point they do the whole Sage
deal and all of that
and then Amy's like okay well I'm gonna
go through all the data that we
collected like why would you at your
house and then we're gonna decide like
on a plan of action like what we're
gonna do
so a few weeks later
um Amy comes back to do another
cleansing and goes into uh romy's room
and she's like meditating or whatever in
there and she said that while she was
doing this
she quote unquote made contact but she
determined that whatever this thing was
in the house wasn't a person they're
like it wasn't a dead person it wasn't a
ghost it wasn't a demon it wasn't
anything like that she said it was just
energy so I'm guessing she was saying
that it wasn't like an intelligent uh
thing you know what I mean
so she's like At first she told Romy
she's like well what you need to do is
just like forcefully tell this thing
like to go away
so after Amy leaves
um Romy starts feeling like really
really sick and then she gets like
really mad and starts like yelling at
this Spirit which she thinks his Spirit
like tell it to get the [__] out right
and so then she calls Amy up again
like presumably for help or advice or
something but in Amy's house apparently
she sees like a black shadow like
materializing like up in the like on the
um corner of the ceiling like in her
house
and so she's like she's like looking at
it and she's like um you know yelling at
it to leave or whatever so she calls
Romy basically like why is your [__]
Poltergeist [__] like over at my house
now like thanks a lot yeah so yeah so
she's figured out she's like okay well
this thing is essentially a poltergeist
and like Romy is the focus so she's the
one causing it and she has determined
that uh Romy is evidentially evidently
and evidently
um manifesting her anxieties into a
being or like into some kind of energy
that's causing changes
so like a psychic Golem yeah so like
when she tells her that Romy said she it
kind of made sense and she was like
then she started feeling really bad and
like really guilty because she's like
all of this time I've been
subconsciously like tormenting the
family that I was trying to protect all
of this time like putting my family in
danger and she's like and it was me she
wasn't doing it on purpose you know what
I mean because we've talked about that
before
but she just said she felt really guilty
about it and then
um then they kind of like wrapped the
whole thing up a little bit it was a
little bit anticlimactic because they
were like well over the years I guess
like the manifestation sort of like
lessened like eventually but they said
that Romy was still struggling with it
and she that's she calls it her curse
hence why the episode is called cursed
um Amy is basically like well anytime we
have a situation like that we always
advise therapy because obviously
you have some kind of like mental issues
that is causing you to uh act out in uh
Poltergeist sort of ways which is uh not
a good thing pushing your grandson down
the stairs and all that other kind of uh
stuff if we're if presuming that all of
this is true like that this story is it
fits with what went down with my family
me and my family yeah
it doesn't it it lacks
it lacks a lot of key Poltergeist
um features though
I never really mentioned objects being
thrown or teleported or they did or did
they no that's usually like one of the
first things that happens
or knocking sounds scratching scratching
sound things that's very coming from
walls
um
what's another real common one would Ben
um well they did say that there were
feelings of being watched but mostly
things like
objects appearing or appearing or
disappearing like right in your midst
you set a glass down and turn the graph
so you go back to the glass the glass is
gone and you find it downstairs in the
cupboard that that kind of [__] you know
I have that happen every now and then so
you do well it hadn't happened for a
while but I think well last time I was
still at the old house okay and then the
[__] was going on there yeah yeah
because I went in the bathroom and like
I put my Razor down like that and then
like I went and do something yeah yeah I
was like God damn it were you sitting
there and then it starts and then if you
give it too much attention and if if you
get spooked by it it starts acting up
even more and you're sitting there and
you might just something just fall out
of the damn thin air you didn't see it
in materializer and then you just see it
in motion and it'll hit and not bounce
and it might be a coin or something or a
key and poop who catches it yeah
and I was like I've been looking for
that she's like she had the kids my
motorcycle key it was gone for about
three days
yeah we tore the [__] house up
looking for that [__] we couldn't find
that thing anyway playing with poking
she was down by my feet and I saw
something fall and her catch it and she
had the key in her hand and she was
nibbling on it that's the key
she's like you know this is my toy I
didn't see it materialize out of air out
of thin air or anything
I was looking down it was already in
motion
but I saw it fall maybe about three four
inches and she grabbed it
you know pretty cool Poltergeist game
Pokey the key to play with
the only thing because it knows that she
likes to chew on rubbery things the only
thing that's happened here recently was
guess it was almost a year ago
I was pissed off and I was looking for
something and my eyes were scanning
across the top of I don't remember what
I might have been looking for the
motorcycle key again
you're always losing that [__] well that
in your glasses he's always using his
glasses I think it takes the glasses
probably and um um
my my eyes were skinning across the top
of a uh of a bookcase that I have there
and
it hit a stainless steel ring that was a
skull
and as soon as my eyes went off of it
it flew up about three inches
and fluttered down to the ground
like a leaf
it didn't go straight down it went side
to side
and I went wait a minute and looked down
and there it was like it was so natural
and so normal
that I was looking away from it when it
fluttered down slowly to the ground
like a piece of paper or a leaf but it
was a big stainless steel ring
and I just kept going because
when the phenomenon happens I don't
notice it a lot of times it seems normal
because I'm I'm in a different state of
mind like when the remote flew off and
our friends saw it we flew off the table
I was so I was pissed off but I was so
unaware of it I saw it go but I didn't
care and it hit yeah hit the ground and
made a loud noise pow I don't even think
it bounced it just stuck
and they freaked out and I was I didn't
even care
and I went oh yeah yeah they did happen
didn't it I was like yeah yeah that was
weird wasn't it and I was standing there
my hair started to stand up on the back
of my neck and I looked down there was a
stack of coins at my feet
well I said before this is what I said
why does it do something useful like
bring me some bring me some money yeah
and my hair started standing up there
you go there was a stack of cords in my
feet but that was from the dresser yeah
it didn't bring any new money no no just
right here have some change from the
other I was imagining like a [__] an
entire pallet of crisp 100 bills see
that's the bank right that's what I was
[__] see that's what I would have
wanted right I mean we could still you
can still do that you still got the
powers
just manifest
manifest it I'll help you I'm I'm
thinking about it right now yeah I'm
thinking about it right now you can't
just right there in the middle of the
floor
you can't consciously do it although you
see I want a pallet of money that's why
I wanted to talk to the Rain Man Donnie
Deckard because he could consciously do
it it's one of the and the prison
wardens and everything saw it and the
the prison and the prison guards making
it rain in his cell like like a torrent
torrential rain inside his [__] cell
then he hit he hit the warden with a Big
Blob of water
and he was on in his office on the other
side of the
prison
the prison guards are like hit the ward
can you hit him because yeah I got him I
can get him he was getting him anyway
I got him and then he went over there to
go see the ward and he had a big old
spot of water
in his shirt he didn't know where it
came from
instead of he said a round ball of water
hit him in the chest it would have been
cooler if it was like something that was
more like provable like something that
was like well they were scared of him
like how about like mayonnaise or
something like something more noticeable
or something that you wouldn't
necessarily have just like
they were because water that'd be like
the prison guards were scared of him
they said being around him was just like
being around death
death and depression because that's he
was real super depressed and Rain would
just become out of the walls out of
nowhere inside his cell just like Eeyore
yeah
all the water shifted off of him and out
of the priest
and the guard said that said it was
weird and rain and it all just focused
in on that priest while he was trying to
read that Bible
and then it slowly went away and he got
out of jail
but it did even better [__] with his
house the cops saw it and everything was
raining inside his house before he
before he went to jail
yeah
it made it rain in the restaurant too
didn't he
uh did he take him to a restaurant it
started raining in the restaurant yeah I
think so it was a pizza parlor
speaking of which Camp guy said I was
cooking a frozen pizza and then about an
hour later I found a burn Pizza in my
oven what the [__]
and Ben said the Lord works in
mysterious
Ben said I used to have one of those
skull rings that disappeared Into Thin
Air one day maybe that's just something
your skull rings do uh one of my
girlfriends gave it to me the one of my
biker girlfriends gave it to his biker
wife yeah
she got one shoulder up here the other
shoulder down there really yeah remember
she's the one that got crunched up in
that accident you didn't tell me that
yeah
that's funny she's funny especially when
she's smoking crack when she smoke a
crack she's really funny
[Laughter]
she's got about it you know you're much
you're much funnier when you're on crack
yeah yeah she's still got about half her
teeth probably yeah
she was flirting she's about 50. and she
had on she goes look at all those riches
I have and he goes he came in here and
he gave me all these I said who did he
was this guy you know yeah this is the
guy this guy yeah she had all these
stainless steel rings of different kinds
and one of them was a scar that says I'm
gonna take that one she goes oh you
gonna take it I said yeah I'm Gonna Take
It
then he goes what's this mean and I says
we're married
she's like okay okay
she's gonna sue you for alimony one of
these days
I'm with my my other wife she's like you
tell her I said hello
he's funny she's cool with it yeah yeah
I got her the [__] I got I got other
women
funny
[Laughter]
it's all a game it's all a game
probably waiting for you to bring her
some crack
she never asked for crack
these guys she's got she's got she's got
old crackheads buying her crack
that's a cracked scene you know
I'm a little [__] 60 year old 70 year
old crackheads probably hidden
you know yeah I got some crack come on
let's go around the back you know that's
what we're talking about yeah
I mean you know
you can't taking that [__] seriously man
all right little [__] bikers
well they're having a good time probably
yeah she does she doesn't have a
motorcycle she just ends up on them you
know
she's what they call her mama yeah yeah
she just kind of belongs to everybody
yeah yeah all right well that's fine get
on her back we're going okay
[Laughter]
talk real sweet to me baby I'm gonna get
you some teeth
is
classy out there
I gotta say though they're [__]
hilarious
real friendly
well yeah you know all right so um so I
guess that was the end of the episode
wasn't it yeah
but uh yeah that was actually a good
episode I had forgotten all about that
one yeah it was good I had forgotten all
about that one and I had forgotten that
it was uh about a poltergeist even
though they didn't tell you that until
the very end yeah but you know so uh how
long we've been going
hour and 12 minutes okay that's perfect
perfectly yeah yeah because it's like
where we are it's nine o'clock and I
still gotta take a shower and get [__]
ready for work tomorrow because I gotta
get up really early so you know sorry we
started a little bit late but we didn't
start that late it was like 20 minutes
late something like that it didn't seem
to be just uh bothering anybody no I
guess not we still making money
we're not making money
all right yeah so um we're like I said
we're probably not gonna do a movie
review tomorrow night but we will do the
Regular Show on Wednesday night and the
Regular Show we're doing another True
Crime one is gonna be about oh Rodney
Alcala The Dating Game Killer which I've
been wanting to cover that guy for a
long time and I
thought we had done them already but I
guess not even if we actually I'm gonna
go look and we probably already did but
no I think we didn't do that guy
so I'm kind of excited about it uh so
that's what we're gonna do on Wednesday
night so hopefully you guys can all make
it then where it's like we're gonna
start at 7 30 again because like I said
you know I don't get home until 6 00 or
6 15 or something like that so I like to
have a little bit of time to kind of get
ready
so uh yeah so we'll see you guys again
on Wednesday night thanks for dropping
by have a good rest of your evening have
a good day tomorrow and we'll see you on
Wednesday night